I never really thought my path in life
was actually taken
to be an astronaut
I just didn't think this mission is
gonna be so emotional here we sit
I don't even have tennis shoes now I get
a water without any shoes it's our
future right there in space
Association Space Station
we'll just ask me what's it like to work
for NASA and
it's amazing
how do you like space so far it's really
amazing no I love it
I'm just these rocks we're gonna find it
I hope we can find the rocks we're gonna
find it
are you gonna help us find them oh hey
do you know who the rocks are I don't
think there's anyone there
we'll find them okay we can find rocks
we we don't we don't need you you don't
need you you need you all right we're
done hey let's go over here okay all
right